here
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
christopher hitchens
what is your view about the american
literary community's response to the
death warrant
issued by the ayatollah against the
author of satanic vs salman rushdie
well tomorrow is the birthday of george
washington
and tomorrow
the
shopping malls of the united states
which contain now one-third of the book
outlets in this country will
will of their own volition not sell that
book because they're scared of a foreign
despot
now in my opinion for that to happen in
this country on washington on
washington's birthday to be scared of a
crazy foreign tyrant
in this way is a really serious
challenge to what we think of as the
safe assumption
of free speech and uh free inquiry free
expression and the necessity to defend
it and in a way though i find all this
very depressing
i welcome it because
maybe we need every generation also to
remind ourselves that
it's not a free ride to have free
expression not a free ride to have a
free society and that it does need to be
defended but this has gone off to a very
bad start very bad start
christopher hitchens is our guest our
phone lines are open the subject is how
america in the world literary community
including publishers is responding to
the salman rusty situation the phone
lines are open you can begin dialing now
we'll spend a few more minutes with our
guest and then we'll open the phones to
you area code 202-628-2525
is the number for those of you living
and calling from the eastern and central
time zones those living and calling from
the mountain in pacific time zones
202-783-2727 those outside the united
states dial the appropriate country code
and then 202
737-6734 is the number for you
there's a story in the washington post
on saturday this past weekend headlines
silence in the eye of the rusty storm
fear has swept the north american
literary and publishing establishment in
the wake of ayatollah khamenei's death
sentence on novelist salman rushdie
author of the satanic verses
even talked about canada barring
importation of the books do you want to
characterize any of that yeah look i
mean i know that a lot of people who
will in the ordinary way when it's some
imprisoned czechoslovakian playwright
like vaclav havel who's actually on
trial this week or someone in chile or
south africa or poland will you know
automatically sign there's a list
everyone sort of knows it people you can
call
famous american writers who will put
their names to a defense of the freedom
of others not so fortunate in this case
some of these people
decided to pass
and some of them
one of them is quoted in that story said
it was because they were frightened and
for me the most depressing moment of
reading that story was when arthur
miller said that i mean arthur miller
was a hero to many of us when we were
young before we were writers because of
his tremendous bravery in the face of
the mccarthy hearings
and the play that he wrote and the plays
and books that he's written on the theme
of free expression
that he should say that he is scared to
associate with a protest where a
writer's life
has been directly threatened where his
books are being burned and the threat is
that he will be burned too
um
it just
makes me very sad
now the same justification i don't think
applies to bookstores like b dalton
and walden books who've pulled the book
from their shelves deprived americans of
the chance to read the book for
themselves
that's a merely commercial consideration
they haven't been threatened they aren't
no one's asked to go on tv and show
their face and say
you know give the ayatollah the lie and
say all right i don't care what you
think i prefer to exercise my rights
and then we have sorry to drone on bruce
but just one final thing before
i think it's been very sad that the
the religious leaders of the country
have been so feeble they've all
either said nothing or as in the case of
cardinal archbishop o'connor of new york
have said they think the book is
blasphemous and they've as it were
directed their criticism at their book
instead of calling the ayatollah mania
blasphemer for using religion to mount a
contract killing which is what he's
publicly done
so that's my
take since you asked all right and we've
got you here in part because you wrote
this column that appeared in the friday
edition of the new york times now who
will speak for rusty
what's the reaction you've gotten uh to
this column
well nice for you to ask i mean it
shouldn't be me who says but actually
the response was very positive i think a
lot of people have rung me from around
the country
saying it's what they wanted to read
which pleased me very much i think look
the piece is full of cliches
i say all the obvious stuff all the
things that we take in with our milk we
know expression freedom from fear and so
on but there are certain days when
cliches come alive and i apparently was
lucky
to publish my cliches on friday because
friday last because that was when people
wanted to meet them
youngstown ohio first call for
christopher hitchens go ahead please yes
mr uh i would like to address myself
first of all i am a model but i don't
adhere to the humane doctrine of islam
my question is even though i believe in
the absolute freedom of expression
by anybody there is always a fine line
where a sensible intellectual and
educated person like
should really
recognize
secondly
freedom of speech does not allow anybody
anybody to be also extremist
to the extent that he insult one billion
muslim
the second comment i would like to
address the host of this program
i've been
seeing this program for a long time and
i admire it very much but so far every
time there is an issue between arab and
israelis or muslim and non-muslim you
never ever bring to your program anybody
represent the other view if there is
really freedom of speech and you believe
in it you should adhere yourself to it
and you should allow the other side to
present their view all your guests so
far they were representing the opposite
view why don't you allow us we are 8
million muslim in america we
have a right to be represented in your
program and we have many muslim scholars
they would like to present the review in
your program all right sir thank you
i'll respond to that after we hear from
mr
hitchens um
there's uh there's a mistake at the
heart of what you say sir you say that
though you are for free speech
you aren't for the exercise of free
speech
if it offends muslims and you say that
that is the line that we draw as a
matter of fact you're in error first
amendment to the constitution uh allows
anyone who wants to to insult anyone
they like
in any way they choose that includes
belief in religion which is especially
given no
particular protection
by that amendment which is in fact
rightly described as the cornerstone of
our
liberty now
that's just the fact of the matter i can
say what i like about your religion and
you can say what you like about my
humanism
and i will
not attempt to prevent you
from doing that in fact so far from that
i would defend anyone who tried to make
you be silent
that is the foundation of what we call
the enlightenment it's terrible to have
to be saying this
because it's abc but there it is now to
your point about the insult
i have read the book i don't know if you
have
and
i'm clear in my mind that no insult to
the prophet or to those who believe in
the god of whom he's the messenger
is intended
uh the
words that are complained of are spoken
by a sick man
suffering from paranoid schizophrenia in
a dream in which he believes himself to
be the archangel gabriel who is a
christian icon so i think that's about
as far fictionally as you could go
to avoid the
charge of blasphemy but i must add that
if someone rushed he had wished to be
blasphemous had wished to challenge the
tenets of your faith that would also be
his right so don't confuse me in giving
you two answers i mean them to be
separate but related
and to the caller i would say that uh we
make every effort here to
have a balanced presentation of all
issues i'm certain i know that we've had
representatives from the arab and the
muslim worlds both
paid lobbyists as it were and other
journalists and the like perhaps you'd
prefer to see a greater proportion than
we've had on or you've simply missed the
ones that you've had on either case i
urge you to keep watching and you will
see over the course of time a balanced
presence issue presentation on this and
all the other issues that uh come up for
discussion on this program tulsa
oklahoma is next go ahead please
uh yes
first of all i'd like to know why has it
taken the so long for the u.s government
to respond to iran's statements of
killing rusty and
what do you think the united states will
do
to iran for this if anything's going to
be done
well it certainly is true that the first
statement made by secretary of state
baker was fantastically weak i mean he
said
that he thought the murder threat was
regrettable which is i think i don't see
really that you could have chosen a more
feeble word than that
um
president bush today has i think said
intolerable which is an improvement but
not an enormous one
for the united states there are two
problems one is
you have no diplomats anymore in iran no
one to withdraw
unlike the european countries unlike the
european countries who have no
ministerial visits that you can cancel
that are in preparation
actually things could barely be worse
plus there are american hostages in the
custody of people supposedly pro iranian
and probably pro promeni
so
that's all difficult however i do think
that something a little more daring
could have been said about the founding
principles of the american republic
where they're attacked in this way after
all damage has already been done
simon rushjes had to cancel his trip to
united states that's to say
americans have already been robbed of
the chance to meet him see him for
themselves
meet him at book signings and so on many
americans have been deprived by other
americans american book seller
monopolies of the right to buy the book
in other words we're giving ground to
the ayatollah just at the point where
his regime is crumbling his revolution
is at a dead end
his credibility is in shreds even in his
own country
at just this moment
um it seems to me appalling that people
should start crying out before they've
been hurt and giving ground
to what i described before and would
describe again as a foreign despot we
have half an hour left with christopher
hutchins before the next call let me ask
you a response to this argument that
those
publishers who are withdrawing the books
and those authors who might not be
speaking out have and that is
um it's one thing to respond to another
publisher who's banning a book or uh to
a citizens group but here we're dealing
with a terrorist head of state that
justifies our action
well i don't see where the distinction
comes i mean the fact is that these
struggles for freedom of expression
freedom of speech have always been
indivisible and they've often required a
victory over fear i mean that's and
they've often i'm afraid to say
it necessitated a confrontation with
people who have deeply religious ideas
it was deeply religious people
who didn't want the bible translated
into english and burned the first two or
three translators william tyndale being
the best known
deeply religious excuse me religious
people
tried to prevent galileo from pointing
out that the
earth goes around the sun and not the
other way around deeply religious people
did it to sir thomas more
there are countless other cases
[Music]
unfortunately if that is backed by state
power that only means it must be opposed
that much more strongly and
in a more unified way wenatchee
washington state go ahead please
yes i'm i want to challenge this
assertion
that there should be no restrictions on
free speech or in writing i know the
news men are always
all against any restrictions but years
ago
i happened to be in new york and orson
well had a radio program
and on this program
he talked about an invasion
by the martians
well it created a panic in new york all
the telephones were were tied up for for
hours
no no ambulance and calls could go
through
lord knows how many people may have died
just on canada now
i want the your guest
to answer me if he believes that that
was should be freedom obviously yes
question answers itself
orson welles has the right to put on a
play people have the right to behave
like fools and
lemmings when they hear it
um she had the right actually what that
was was a reaction to the very
early days of radio where there was
still something quite mysterious about
the wireless and as british used to call
it
messages from the ether and people
weren't very familiar with it it had
nothing at all to do
with the exercise of free speech and i'm
afraid to say banning orson welles to
try to stop people being of a panicky
disposition would be
wouldn't even be putting the cart
anywhere near the horse
wouldn't that be the equivalent though
of yelling fire in a crowded theater
which is not a protected speech um
yelling firing at crowded theater is not
an act of drama or literature or
novelistic or any other kind of
production
oklahoma city you're next go ahead
please uh yeah i just wondered what the
decision of
walden books and
b dalton says about the fact of you know
large corporations controlling
distribution of literature in this
country
well i think it shows a generally
depressing tendency towards monopoly
towards
uh corporatization of the market and
towards standardization of the market
and towards
the selling of books as if they were
shoes or exercise
manuals or videos or whatever
in a way that's a good thing i mean it
means that you can go
to a mall and buy a book while you're
thinking of buying something else or
other members of your family doing other
things but it has led to a tremendously
um restrictive
model for the outlet of books and in
return for books being marketed as
commodities they've also been
put at the mercy of a very small number
of distributors
you're a rather high profile person in
your own right columnist for the nation
magazine having written this column that
appeared in the new york times have you
gotten any uh threats of any kind no i
haven't do you expect any um well i had
to say to my wife what about this i've
got to go on tv and do this and that and
what do you think we have a child and he
goes to school in washington
and i'm in the phone book by the way um
i think it's my right to be in the phone
bill um
and she said no um she comes from a
country where there was a dictatorship
once and people came to her house and
pushed her around and so on and the fact
is there's only one way you can respond
to it
we've had
braver friends than ourselves in the
past in countries of persecution
and one's often wondered well what would
it be like well the fact is this is not
a fair test all we have to do now
is not abandon the principles we have
anyway nothing heroic is demanded
newton massachusetts go ahead please
yes i am a first-time caller and a
reader of the nation
and um i wanted to um
uh first of all i'm an atheist and i
wanted to uh emphasize the fact that um
i have the right the right to ridicule
anybody's religion but i would would
absolutely fight for their right to
believe to believe it
and i wanted to get your um
your views on canada's uh these hate
laws because i believe they were put
into place because of a a person who
wrote some
garbage about the holocaust not not ever
existing and
this is what happens when bad law goes
into effect
because of
freedoms to say um really lunacy if
somebody wants to publish it uh i just
thought i'd like to hear what you'd have
to say on that
yeah um
look
it's another of my famous cliches i was
describing earlier they come alive at
moments like this you say freedom's
indivisible how many times have you
heard that well it turns out to be true
um
the law in canada was indeed passed in
order to protect the susceptibilities of
canadian jews and and it was used to
prosecute someone who wrote
a very unpleasant pamphlet saying that
the holocaust had not taken place and
was a jewish fabrication actually the
guy went to jail
now a number of us at the time wondered
if that was a proper use of laws
governing speech and i also wondered if
it would stop there and of course it
never does you give the state a law like
that and what's it going to do but find
it convenient
i come from a country that doesn't have
a first amendment and i know how that
works
uh often i think americans don't realize
how lucky they are that they have a
first amendment that doesn't allow this
um i should say i'd like to add one
thing to that if i could
um salman rushdie who is someone i know
and admire
has in britain stuck up consistently for
the rights of the muslim minority he's
defended also the rights of muslim
peoples overseas who he thinks have been
carelessly
disregarded or brutally treated by
powerful western countries he's got a
very good
record on all this it strikes me as
particularly hateful that he should be
the object of this murder campaign by
by a leader who claims to speak for
islam
thousand oaks california is next go
ahead please
hello
i was just wondering if you believe that
the decision by the ayatollah to go
after rushdie was
like a blind grasp for a scapegoat
as as in the case of
a power or a regime that is losing power
in order to help them
in world standing and to combine all
their people for one purpose again
yeah i do suspect that and i thought the
same when the campaign of violence began
which actually if you remember was
shortly before the ayatollah's
murder and
bounty threat in pakistan it was very
noticeable the people besieging the
american buildings in karachi
were the sort of people who had just
lost the election the former muslim
extremists have been grouped around um
general zia's dictatorship and who are
looking for a way of regrouping and an
issue with which to appeal to people
i think there's something of the same is
happening in iran ayatollah khomeini has
called for many holy wars lately and
he's called on people to martyr
themselves for him in countless ways and
and i'm afraid to say
heaps of dead and and
numberless uncounted
unknown graves as a result of his policy
i have the feeling that the willingness
of his people to take him at his word
and martyr themselves afresh is
slackening
i think he knows that too and i think
therefore it's in a sense doubly
incumbent on us
not to give in to somebody who is in
fact behaving
out of desperation who's at their
weakest point who's trying to prevent
a reformation spreading to the islamic
world by its contact from the
enlightenment who wants to stop that
um i think we should be very forcible in
resisting it and trying to turn the
process the other way and to synthesize
with the islamic world
certain ideas that they don't belong to
europe they don't belong to america
they're common to humanity that we call
the ideas of the enlightenment
i should mention that before we go too
far along that in addition to being a
columnist for the nation you're the
author of a book of essays prepared for
the worst
what's in it
well i'll tell you what's on it which is
on the dust jacket i'm proud to say
there's a recommendation from salman
rushdie that you buy and read it and i
hope this doesn't mean it's pulled from
the shelves
but it's a collection of essays about
the reagan era about thomas paine the
great englishman who became also a great
american
and who wrote the crisis and who in a
sense contributed some of the finer
amendments to the constitution um
so it's a it's a general collection of
essays in defense of the ideas of
liberty if i do say it myself
i'm sadly modest but
um you want to mention out loud your
country of origin
yes in case uh anyone thought it was
anywhere else i was born in in the
united kingdom of great britain and
northern ireland i'm english i've been
living here for
about 10 years now but i'm told that the
accident is still
noticeable
before the next call how do you think
all of this will play out
in terms of the viability of freedom of
expression let's say a year from today
well my hope is that it's healthy that
that
this will in fact have confirmed people
that it's a sort of exercise that's good
for the muscles that have gone slack we
don't often have to in our very own
homes and malls and shopping centers
have to think gosh what's the price of
free expression i think it might be
profoundly educational i hope it doesn't
turn into just
defending ourselves against islam or
against the ayatollah because
there are people always in all societies
and this one who would like to tell us
what they think it's okay for us to read
very often using religion as their
excuse
and
they deserve to be repudiated too
as they were in the past it was
necessary to repudiate them to have
america to have the american revolution
so i'm optimistic if we can get through
this and if
salman is not hurt
if his isolation can be ended and
there's every chance i think that it can
i think it would have been good we've
got about 20 minutes left with
christopher hitchens next call for him
orlando florida you're on the air
yes i'd like to speak about terrorism
here
you know we have the dirty dozen movies
uh a few years ago
and why don't we send out all our
criminals except for child molesters and
serial killers
and all the real creeps
and send them out there and fight for us
because this is how our country started
this is how australia started
tell you what color do you have any
comment you want to make about the uh
issues surrounding the
price on salmon rusty's head and the
effect on this man has a right to say
what he wants to say
and publish a book or do anything he
wants to do
we have that's right in the united
states but people lying on the stand
here in this country
they go out to courts and they see
police officers lying yes ma'am but i'd
like you to make a comment regarding the
very purpose of christopher hitchens
visit here today do you have a comment
on that subject yes i do because
people have
also a right to be honest
but honesty doesn't work doesn't
it's proven all across the world that if
you're honest you're a victim all right
ma'am thank you very much
um comment
nothing immediate washington dc is next
go ahead please
yes i think that
one of the most important elements here
that it is not being talked about so
much is the internal situation in iran
which is the prime reason romania has
involved itself in this ridiculous show
i think in the past six months uh romani
has killed somewhere around 12 000 of
the opponents in iran
and it is indeed
uh because he doesn't have the issue of
war anymore at hand and i think that
romani is trying to here use this issue
to somehow divert the attentions from
his uh
really
poor situation inside iran and
the most interesting uh thing that i
find in this uh whole episode is that
uh this idea of i think moderates and
hardliners are really ridiculous and as
long as romani regime is in power we're
gonna have the same sort of terrorism
and ridiculous things under the name of
islam i'm a muslim and i'm really
opposed to this whole
[Applause]
show and
i was wondering what's your opinion of
this idea of moderate and hardliners
thank you yeah well that's an admirable
statement and it may possibly have come
from somebody tuned in late because i
had been saying earlier sir that i i did
think this was
this campaign both in pakistan and in
iran originated from political extremist
conservative forces who felt their hold
on the situation to be slackening and i
agree with what you say about that
um especially in view of the fact of the
great crusade the great holy war in
which so many iranians did lose their
lives is now over and hasn't come out as
the ayatollah wanted or predicted that
it would
um of course you're right about the
moderate business and and the
the earlier caller who asked me why i
thought the us government had been so
silent and rather shame-faced on the
question um
and he prompts me to give her another
answer now i mean i think there is still
in high circles in washington a
tremendous embarrassment about this
absurd pretense that they were dealing
with
people who they moderate were extremist
enough to deal only in weapons
and i'd just say that people should
blush about that um there are i mean
indeed there have been some i've had
debates on
in public with reaganites who
in a sense defend the ayatollah's
position and say of course he can
campaign against blasphemy if he wants
to people like pat buchanan who was
reagan's
communication secretary at that point
but he
i think was speaking buchanan has to say
as a religious extremist himself and one
who sees a solidarity between them
that you know overcomes denominations um
that's why i began by attacking um the
statement made by john cardinal o'connor
yesterday but usually if you criticize
a religious leader in america you get
people ringing up all the time but no no
one yet well we've still got 14 minutes
but let me ask you you characterized you
told us what was in the book you've read
it
you want to offer your own critical view
as to whether it's a good read
is it a good novel good story yeah i did
actually review it in uh in print about
but in a small magazine about two weeks
ago and i said the following i mean
russia is a genius with language
but there's a difficulty
which if you're starting the book today
you should bear in mind
he's got an absolutely magnificent ear
and his ear is brilliant at catching the
nuances and the tone of people who speak
in
indian pakistani subcontinental english
he's fantastically good at this makes
almost poetry out of the prose
unfortunately that's not very well
understood here as it is in england
there aren't that many people from the
subcontinent in america
so the first couple of chapters may not
strike you as being as funny as they
really are but i think by the third you
may well be hooked but do
do persist and i think you'll also find
that the remarks made about religion
are all
uh carefully judged remarks about
dogma about people who have automatic
unthinking faith
and no one who has any genuine
devotional attachment to any religion
could be
offended
eugene oregon go ahead please you're on
the air um
yes if russia is in fact killed
what response would you predict britain
or the united states to take or or what
kind of action could they feasibly take
there's no way of retaliating in kind
you see it's it's the whole difference
between our use of the word mata or
heretic
and the use
by fanatics of those words when we say
heretic we quite often mean an honorable
thing many of our greatest
political and historical heroes have
been people who willing to brave the
charge of heresy the same with martyrdom
um we say
our faith as humanists doesn't require
the creation of martyrs we can't argue
with people who appear to need to create
them we can't say we'll go and kill an
iranian
scribe that would be obscene even if it
was doable
i think
i'm very reluctant to answer the
question without thinking about it very
carefully but
what i think is this if that happens if
by and i don't believe it will because i
think this is a dying regime and a
fanatical despairing
maneuver on its part
but if a hair of his head is hurt or if
and let it be forbidden he should be
killed
i think it would lead to an enormous
revulsion in the muslim world
which might in the long run
contribute to the reformation that that
world so obviously needs and
i can't speak for mr rushdie but i think
he hopes in any case
that this controversy may help to bring
that apart
binghamton new york you're on the air
uh thank you just for christopher
hitchens and uh there's a couple points
in your first answer
you said as i think basically everything
i've read on the problem
is that
blasphemy is not really
happening that is it is the dream of
a demented person now my sense is very
strongly i'm not religious it is
quote blasphemy unquote in relation to a
religious person i think that
most of the critics are kind of
hiding and not
coming forward i think rashdi himself
i can understand that he will
try to say it is not but it is
it is a very heavy criticism
the second point is
something that has not been brought up
at all in discussion it's always
remaining on the religious level is to
trace a wonderful subplot
concerning the imam sitting in
kensington
uh and going back
uh it is cl to a country called dash in
this in the in the case of the book but
it is obviously
ayatollah is the image
those two things i think are
if you have anything to say on it
well
you get a very good classic question
from binghamton i must say yes
yes i've been up there once and i
remember it's the same my hometown yeah
it is oh well um
bless me look the word mahound is used
in the novel and my hound is for those
who haven't um
read this yet
an extremely abusive term leveled
against the prophet muhammad by the
crusaders centuries ago
implying that he not just had failed to
be the messenger of god but that he was
actually an emissary of the devil
therefore it's tremendously just to use
the word is that is enough indeed to
offend people uh who don't want to
inquire any further but the word is
specially used in a way that satirizes
its use he
salman says in the book look i use it
just as so many other words began as
terms of abuse
impressionist for example began as a
term of abuse for the school of painting
that adopted suffragette was a term of
abuse for campaigners for women's rights
black was a term for abuse at one point
the words tori and wig political party
names
both began as terms of abuse people took
the names on themselves as a way of
drawing
the sting if you see what i mean as a
way of inverting them and turning them
back
as satirical ironic weapons against the
intolerant that's what he's attempting
to do it's a very honorable enterprise
it's perfectly justifiable to try
um and we could go even further into
this but i i did also say it at the
beginning and i do still insist that if
he had wanted simply to be
offensive and to say this religion is
nonsense as far as i can see that's also
his right
columbus georgia you're on the air
yes good evening um
i was born and raised in the middle east
i'm not christian i'm not muslim i'm a
christian
and it seems to me like um
the west we don't understand the islamic
world period
uh i have a couple of things i'd like to
mention
the the muslim world or the arab world
always looks uh at the west with
suspicious because the west never
accepted the fact that muhammad is the
final word from god to mankind
the second thing uh
the muslim leaders or the muslim
leadership in the uh if it's in the uh
arab world or iran or anywhere in the
world in the islamic world
use the scary tactics
uh to scare their followers and they
rallied their followers by scaring them
or use religion
for political motives for their own
benefits i i don't think really
anything's wrong with the wish this book
by expressing his opinion
but then you take the percentage of the
educated people in that part of the
world the ones they read the book
they're very very few
and the ones they
rate it public couldn't understand it
well
but they used it for their own benefits
to manipulate the public opinion their
own countries to to rally the support
for the failing regimes like the
humanes and and so forth so i think you
know we have to look at their background
how they think and how they operate and
take actions according to their actions
not how we'd like to be judged but how
they judge us in the west uh according
to their standards not our standards
okay sir thank you
yeah good fair observation i mean but i
would strengthen a bit what you say
about they haven't read it and may not
have understood it even if they have
they can't have read it it's not
available even in english
in the muslim world and most people in
the muslim world speak either arabic or
farsi or urdu and it hasn't been
translated into any of those and then
you have to remember that unfortunately
these regimes coexist with a very very
high level of illiteracy furthermore and
finally there's a commandment that you
don't read such books if you're told
they're unclean or impure or blasphemous
so the there are about four or five
reasons why these people and their
leaders cannot know what they're talking
about now that in a way
is what's frightening about this
challenge because it's a challenge that
is proud of being ignorant and that thus
one with which it's very difficult to
compromise
los angeles california
yes uh my concern is not necessarily
with the
first amendment right which we have in
which we use freely my concern is with
the publishers and with the bookstores
and as an author i was wondering if this
gentleman could make any suggestions as
to how we might apply pressure on those
entities who in fact are really denying
me my right by no longer publishing it
and no longer selling it to buy it
caller have you tried to buy the book
yes and what were you told
it's not available you tried it in the
change stores yes sir what about uh
independent stores uh no i haven't well
i think there's some good advice in
yesterday's new york times and someone
with whom
i almost never agree
um though i admire him as a writer
william sapphire who says go browse at b
dalton and go browse at walden books and
see what you want to buy and then go to
your nearest independent bookstore and
spend your money there
that's the best way to punish them it's
a little extra trouble
but i think worth it and it's it is the
only language currency that they
understand then i think and hope
we may hear soon from the pen
organization which groups american
authors and international writers
of some bankable famous authors who will
say they don't want their books
sold in these chains too there is talk
of this i mean that's the most i know
for now but that i think would be a very
fitting
reply what's your response to the
argument of the chain owners who say
we're just trying to protect our
employees and our customers well my
response would honestly be
that
dues have to be paid they make a good
living out of the fact that we have
freedom of speech so do i it's how i
make my living but i recognize that that
doesn't come from the sky it wasn't
given me by god it's the result of a
willingness to sacrifice by people
earlier on
the dues were asking them to pay not
very great they haven't been threatened
for one thing there is no threat against
the distribution of the book the
injunction does not apply to them the
injunction applies to the author and his
publishers
so they're crying before they've been
hurt
second
if they worry about security deal with
the security but you don't you don't
make us any more secure by removing the
book
silver spring maryland go ahead please
yeah i i don't want to talk about
blasphemy or the muslim mindset
what i really want to say is that this
reminds me
of
the reaction we have
a lot of americans sit around every time
we have a book on the holocaust
and they say how did all those good
germans
let it all happen
well it happens when we have a
commission on pornography and playboy
and penthouse
disappear from 7-eleven and k-mart's and
then it happens with this kind of thing
happening with
the bookstores and and the fear
and we're so self-righteous about other
people
who didn't stand up and be counted
and
when we're asked to count
we turn tail and run so often
and freedom
isn't going to last that way
thank you silver spring
well put but there are always people
like yourself madame evidently which is
the encouraging thing i mean that's
that's much
more to the point there are invariably
people that the lady who just called who
said no no i'm not going to be treated
like this i'm not going to be told what
to think
um i will decide that for myself and in
the end that idea is going to win
because it's more it's more democratic
it's more intelligent it's more modern
uh it's more efficient to think like
that than than to be
permanently under a mental
cloud we've got enough time to talk more
about the pen organization and what
their plans are are you a member uh i'm
ashamed to say i'm not a member but
they've gained one member um by this you
know there's another thing i thought
i'll pay the jews one day i will now
what they're doing is tomorrow in new
york city
um and
i believe today on the west coast um
holding public readings from the book
with authors stepping to the microphone
in relay holding the book and reading
from it and establishing the right for
it not just to be written
but to be heard and read which is you
know part of the right um
and that will happen in new york city
tomorrow morning at noon in the downtown
gallery and will be carried but i think
on tv i hope so
everyone there will put their names to
saying we
affirm this about the book and then
we'll see if anyone wants to add
us all to the list but i don't believe
it i think we have to face it and say
this is this is a stupid
wicked
bluff and that there's no reason for
anyone to act scared about this sort of
intimidation
christopher hitchens columnist for the
nation and author of a book of essays
prepared for the worst is that in the
stores now yes it is yes not been pulled
from the shelves as over the state they
probably had two more in the stores than
i'd like out of the stores and into the
onto the bookshelves of the reading
public